pourquoi l'afrique résiste mieux on voit
cela avec samuel matthey président de la
fed
la fondation africaine pour
l'entrepreneuriat et le développement
économique
il faut féliciter les pays africains qui
veulent gouvernements africains qu'ils
ont très tôt pris des mesures
restrictives beaucoup de confinement à
travers le continent
on connaîtra le véritable taux de
contamination ou d'infections quand on
fera les tests de masse comme la corée
du sud l'a fait aujourd'hui peut
pratiquement tous les pays c'est le plus
des tests déclaratif
mais ce qu'il faut noter c'est que si
vous prenez la culture ambiante de
l'afrique ya deux choses qui touchent et
essentiellement qu'ils font la
particularité de l'afrique
la première chose c'est que selon la
banque mondiale
40% à 60% de l'économie africaine est
informel c'est à dire que ce sont des
gens qui vivent le joujou qui n'ont pas
de sécurité sociale
donc il est difficile de confiner une
population qui vit le jour au jour donc
vous allez vous retrouver avec 60% des
personnes qui meurent de fait donc le
choix de ces 60 % des personnes qui
meurent de fait et un consens s'ils ne
sont pas confinés qui vont mourir du coc
vide et la culture africaine est une
culture de proximité
c'est une culture de groupe c'est une
culture de famille étendue
donc il est difficile à l'afrique de
pratiquer ces des styles c'est cette
distanciation